ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะน้องแอดตี้สวัสดีครับพี่ถ้านัก
เรียนทุกคนเย้สวัสดีสวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะ
ครับผมกลับมาเจอกันอีกรอบหนึ่งเข้ามา
หนึ่งเจอกลัวตี้กับครูพี่เอ๋ในช่องคอมโพ
เน็นส์เซเบิลไทยนะครับ
ข้างบนนะคะครับ
วันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันที่วันเดิมใช่ไหมวัน
เดิมวันจันทร์หน้าวันพันจำได้วันนี้วัน
จันทร์วันจันทร์ที่เท่าไหร่นะคะวันนี้วัน
ที่ 7 ค่ะเออเออวันจันทร์ที่ 7 ใช่ไหม
ครับอ่ะค่ะตอนที่ 7 นะครับโอเค
นะคะเดือนอะไรนะคะค่ะเดือนนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
เดือนนี้ก็ต้องเป็นเดือนมีนาคมนะครับมี
เดือนมีนาคมใช่ครับนะคะนักเรียนก็ฟัง
มีนาคมมีนาคมมีนาคมกันที่จำได้นะคะก็ได้
แล้วครับมีนางอกแตกแต่บางทีคนไทยก็เลข
เดือนมีนาคมนะเล่นสั้นๆเดือนนี้เดือนมีนา
ไหนชอบพูดสั้นๆนะครับมีนาแล้วปีคศเท่า
ไหร่คะมีคศ 2000  22 ครับปีนี้ 2000  29
ปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีพตด้วยสองปีพ.ศพี่พรรถ
ของคนไทยนะของคนไทยแล้วตีผชของคนไทยปีพ.ศ
2565 ครับ Mini
565 ได้
2565 แล้วในครับตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะตอน
นี้ใช่ไหมครับตอนนี้ก็ทุ่มครึ่งใช่ทุ่ม
ครึ่งแล้วครับตอนนี้หมอ 7:30 นๆครับหิว
ข้าวหรือยังคะพุธที่ไม่หิวคนที่กินแล้วก็
กินอะไร
กูไอ้กินหรือยัง
ยังไม่กินอากูเอตามเราก็ไออยู่ก็ได้คิด
กินอะไรกินอะไรดีกินผักกันกินผัก
ท่องโก๋
โก๋มีกิน
โอเคค่ะอ่างั้นก็วันนี้ครู Arty มีอะไร
บ้านเล่าให้นักเรียนวันนี้ปวดที่จะเล่า
เรื่องกระเป๋าตังไหมเค้าตายใช่กับเวย์มี
ไหมกูเอกก็มีกระเป๋าสตางค์ควรตีก็เตรียม
เตรียมกระเป๋าสตางค์มาให้นักเรียนดูด้วย
เหมือนกันนะครับกี่ใบกระเป๋าสร้างคนที่
หยิบมาแค่ใบเดียวแต่จริงๆแล้วกลัวที่มี
อยู่ 2 ใบมีกระเป๋าสตางค์แบบใบยาวแบบนี้
ไอ้ยาวแบบนี้นะเป็นผ้าป่าแบบนี้ครับเปิด
ออกพับได้ครับแล้วก็มีอีกแบบหนึ่งเดือน
ดับสั้นแบบสั้นอันนี้ก็จะสั้นกว่าสั้น
กว่าครึ่งมาสั้นกว่า
อันนี้ก็ขับถ่ายเหมือนกัน 4 มีน้ำตาของ
ครูอาตี้กระเป๋ายาวๆสีอะไรนะคะหน้า
กระเป๋ายาวสีดำใช้กับดำผ่านเอ้อ
ตั้งในกระเป๋าสตางค์กระเป๋าซ้อนชอบแบบไหน
กระเป๋าสตางค์อ่ะครัวติ๊กเคยใช้แบบนี้แบบ
เนี้ยแบบเนี้ยมันจะดักมันจะหนาๆมันหนา
กว่าตีก็เลยลองเปลี่ยนมาใช้แบบนี้บ้างแบบ
นี้จะบางกว่าจะบางกว่าแต่ว่ามันจะยาวอย่า
เธอใจยาวแต่บางนะครับเค้าต้องเลือกว่าเอา
หนาหรือเอายาว High ชอบแบบยาวเพราะว่า
เวลาที่มีสตางค์ไหมอ่ามี 20 บาท
ไม่ใช่ 55 เฮ้ยเวลาสีฟ้าสีฟ้า 50 โอเค
เวลาใส่สตางค์ในกระเป๋าเนี่ยสตางค์ไม่ไม่
งอๆทรายก็จะไม่มีเอาแบบพับแบบในมีรูปนะคะ
มีรูปมันจะสตางค์จะแบงค์เนี่ยจะงอใจขับ
เหมือนกันแบบนี้พร้อมแบบนี้เพราะว่าใส่
แล้วแบงค์ตรงขอไม่งอใช่ไหมไม่งอค่ะ
ไม่กระเป๋าสตางค์คู๋ใส่อะไรบ้างครับเป็น
หรอดูก่อนได้มั้ย
หัวตี้ปกติควรที่จะใส่เอ่อในกระเป๋าสร้าง
ควรที่จะใส่บัตรวาดหลายๆอย่างหน้ามีบัตร
อะไรบ้างใช่ไหมอ่าบัตรที่จะต้องมีอยู่ใน
กระเป๋าสตางค์ของกวนพี่นะก็จะมีบัตรประชา
ชนบัตรประชาชนไทยมีบัตรประชาชนได้ขับหน้า
มีบัตรประชาชนที่บอกว่าบอกว่าเป็นคน
ประเทศอะไร
จะมีชื่ออาตี้เออนี่มีชื่ออยู่ตรงนี้ที่
อะตี้นามสกุลอะไรนะเอ้อเปิด Ghost ฮ่าๆ
เอาเครื่องอันนี้เป็นชื่อกองยังฟ้องแล้ว
โอเคชื่อแล้วก็มีนามสกุลอยู่บนบัตรประชา
ชนแล้วก็แล้วก็มีมีวันเกิดด้วยครับมีวัน
เกิดอยู่หน้าในบัตรประชาชนนะวันเกิดวัน
ที่เท่าไหร่อ่ะเดือนอะไรปีอะไร
ใช่ครับแล้วก็อ่ามีชื่อมีนามสกุลมีวัน
เกิดแล้วก็มีศาสนาด้วยคะของคนไทยจะต้องมี
ศาสนาด้วยว่านับถือศาสนาอะไรนับถือศาสนา
กว่าตีนับถือศาสนาอะไรคะกลัวที่นับถือ
ศาสนาพุทธครับอ๋อเออใช่ Happy นับถือ
ศาสนาพุทธใช่ครับ
ของคู๋ของพี่เห็นนับถือจะเสื่อพูดมั้ยพูด
ค่ะพูดทักกันที่รักคุณแม่คุณแม่ใช่มั้ย
ท้องจะมาแล้วคุณเอ๋อยู่ใกล้มั้ยเอกคลอด
ฉันไม่ใช่คอร์ดคุณแม่แม่คอร์ดพี่เอ๋
จากสนามพุธขอ
ไงว่าศาสนาพุทธค่ะศาสนาพุทธเหมือนคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่ใช่ไหมควรตีก็ไม่ตัวติดกันนับถือ
ศาสนาพุทธเหมือนคุณพ่อคุณแม่เหมือนกันได้
กูแอบชอบศาสนาพุทธ 5 ไปครับชอบเปิดตี้คิด
ว่านักเรียนนักเรียนหลายๆคนในก็อาจจะมี
ศาสนาของนักเรียนน่ะเรานับถือศาสนาไม่
เหมือนกันก็ได้เฮ้ยได้แล้วแต่ชอบกูเองอ่ะ
ชอบศาสนาพุทธนะคะไม่ใช่เล็กชอบทีอ่ะเล็ก
ชอบไม่ได้นะนับถือแล้วก็ลัทธาแหล่งเงิน
หน้านะคะเราบอกนับถือศาสนาพุทธแต่ครูเอ๋
ก็อ่านนะศาสนาคริปนี้นิดหน่อยศาสนาอิสลาม
อ่านนิดหน่อยก็หายฮินดูก็อ่านนิดหน่อย
ครับอะไรอะอะไรอ่าตอนนี้ครูเอ๋สนใจศาสนา
เชนพี่เชนด้วยเลิกเปิดซิงคลิปเปอร์สอาสนะ
เช่นหรอ kane ก็เป็นศาสนานะเห็นไหมพุทธ
คริสต์อิสลามอินดูซิเลยนะเขตเพลก่อนพุธ
ใช่ไหมอ่อนมีเส้นแล้วก็ค่อยมีพูดคุยก็เลย
สนใจตอนนี้สนใจเทรนนะคะปกติคิดว่าคน
ญี่ปุ่น
คนญี่ปุ่นญี่ปุ่นนับถือศาสนาเชนใช่มั้ย
ใช่ไหมครับชินโตชินโตอ๋ออ๋อเหรอครับ
ตกชินโตแล้วก็พูดนะคะและชินโตกับพูดก็
ใกล้ๆกันนะพูดแบบไทยอ่ะถึงหน้าคล้ายคล้าย
กันใช่มั้ยอ๋อโอเคอ้าก็มีครับในบัตรประชา
ชนก็เขียนว่าเรานับถือศาสนาอะไรใช่ไหมคะ
จะใช้ครับมาประชาชนของคนไทยนะกลัวแต่ไม่
รู้ว่าประชาชนของคนประเทศอเมริกาอังกฤษมี
ศาสนาอยู่ในบัตรประชาชนไหมไม่รู้เดี๋ยวๆ
ก่อนจะรู้ต้องถามว่านักเรียนมีบัตรประชา
ชนไหม
ดีไหมกวนพี่ไม่รู้ว่า
ไม่ๆกูอัดนี่หรอคนคนที่ญี่ปุ่นไม่มีบัตร
ประชาชนอ้าวราครับให้เขาไม่มีบัตรประชาชน
เหมือนเรานะจับปีนี้เหมือนกับต้องมีเขา
เรียก my  number ไปเองไม่รู้ว่าเป็นบัตร
ประชาชนไหมแต่เขาจะดูจากอะไรนะใบขับรถใบ
ขับขี่ขอ
passport ดูจากอะไรไม่รู้แต่ไม่มีบัตร
ประชาชนขอหน่อยครับแต่ใช้บัตรอย่างอื่น
The  Best มีบัตรตายใช่แต่แต่เมื่อ
ประมาณ 3
323 ปีเขาเปลี่ยนเขาเปลี่ยนให้มีบัตรกับ
เขาเรียกเขาเรียกว่า my  number เอกก็ไม่
เข้าใจนะคะแต่คนไทยน่ะมีบัตรประชาชนใช่ๆ
จะไม่รู้อยากรู้นักเรียนมีบัตรประชาชนไหม
อเมริกาน่าจะมีนะ
อเมริกามีไหมน่าจะมีนะมีไหมมีสิก็จะมี
อเมริกามีนักเรียนบอกหน่อยบอกครัวตีหน่อย
ขี้คอมเม้นท์บอกหน่อยถ้ามีนักเรียน
อเมริกามีนักเรียนญี่ปุ่นอยู่ปลอกหน่อย
ว่าประเทศของนักเรียนมีบัตรประชาชนไหม
และได้บัตรประชาชนวันเดือนปีแล้วเนี่ย
ศาสนาแล้วมีอะไรอีกคะถ้ามีที่อยู่ครับที่
อยู่ที่อยู่ที่เป็นบ้านบ้านอยู่หมู่บ้าน
ครัวที่อยู่ที่ไหนก็ดูธุรีอยู่ในบัตร
ประชาชนได้นะก็จะเขียนมาอยู่นนทบุรีอ่ะใจ
ครับจังหวัดพระนั้นพรรคเบื่อนะมีคำถาม
อะไรครับถามว่าอะไรครับอ่ะบ้านครูอัตตีน
อ่ะเขาบัตรประชาชนเนี่ยอยู่นนทบุรีใช่
ครับกับตัวครู Arty อยู่เชียงใหม่ได้ไหม
ฮ่าๆๆครับได้ครับกู a นะบัตรประชาชนเนี่ย
อยู่ชลบุรีอ๋อนะบัตรเนี่ยครูเอ๋อยู่
จังหวัดชลบุรีเอาเป็นบ้านคุณพ่อคุณแม่
แต่งตัวเก๋นะอยู่กรุงเทพฯไม่ได้อยู่
ชลบุรีเหมือนในบัตรไม่ได้อยู่ทีมอยู่คนละ
ที่กันน้อของครัวตี้อยู่ที่เดียวกันใน
บัตรประชาชนนนทบุรีตัวก็อยู่นนทบุรี
เหมือนมีวิธีที่ดีใครค่ะ
ก็มีอะไรในกระเป๋าสตางค์ต้องมีบัตรประชา
ชนบัตรประชาชนมีรูปด้วยมั้ยใช่ครับมีรูป
อยู่ตรงนี้เธอจะได้รู้จะได้รู้อ่ะนี่บัตร
ของครัวตี้หรือเปล่าเออพิบัติของครูเอ๋
หรือเปล่าก๊อกอยู่รูปดูหน้าเหมือนกันนะ
ต้องเหมือนกันทรายไปครับแล้วต้องจำ
นัมเบอร์ของเราได้มั้ยเอ้ออันนี้บัตร
ประชาชนจะมีเลขเลขประจำตัวของจำตัวทุกๆคน
เลขไม่เหมือนกันเลขไม่ดังอันเล็กของครัว
ตี้ไม่เหมือนกับเลขของครูเอกไม่เหมือนไม่
งั้นค่ะกูอะติ๊ดจำได้ไหมคะขวดปิดจำได้
เก็บมากเก่ง
ไม่ได้
ต้องจำให้ก็ได้นะต้องจำเลยได้ทิ้งไป
ไม่เคยจำเลยอะหนุกดีครับสนุกดีครับได้ฝึก
ฝึกฝึกจำตัวเลขกูอ่ะตีมัน 13  Number นะ
ให้เขามี 13 เลขที่บัตรประชาชนมี 13 เลข
13 เลขจำได้ครับจำได้อ่ะ
โอเคในกระเป๋าสตางค์มีบัตรประชาชนมีบัตร
ประชาชนแล้วก็มีมีอะไรอีกไหมใบขับขี่
เป็นใบขับขี่ใบขับขี่นี่คนที่มีบัตรคนที่
ใบขับขี่สามารถขับรถได้ขับรถได้ถ้ามีหมัด
นี้ถ้าไม่มีบัตรนี้ห้ามขับรถค่ะห้ามขับรถ
ใช่ครับ
บ่เคยไม่มีค่ะ
ตัวเองขับรถไม่ได้
ก็เลยไม่ต้องมีใช่ไหมครับไม่ต้องมีเป็นใบ
ขับขี่ให้ครับมั้ยขับขี่และคะขับอ่ะใบขับ
ขี่จะมีมี 2 แบบมีไหมครับมีที่เป็นใบขับ
ขี่รถยนต์ใบขับขี่รถยนต์นั่นเองนะแล้วก็
ใบขับขี่รถมอเตอร์ไซค์อ่ะมิอ้าวใช้ด้วย
กันไม่ได้หรอคะไม่ได้ไม่ได้ต้องมี 2 ใบ
กู Arty แล้วคนคนขับรถบัสคนขับรถวัดต้อง
มีใบขับขี่ของรถบัสตั้งอาจไม่เหมือนกัน
ใช้ใบขับขี่รถยนต์ธรรมดาขับรถบัสไม่ได้
ใช้ใบขับขี่รถยนต์ขับรถมอเตอร์ไซค์ไม่ได้
อ้าว
กู Arty ก็ขับ 2 อย่าง
ได้เพราะกลัวที่มีสองอย่างอ๋อแล้วจะ
เดี๋ยวๆถ้า
สมมุติสมมุติสมมุตินะสมมุติสมมุติเธอไม่
จริงนะคะสมมุติว่าสมมุติว่ากูแอดตี้นั่ง
รถรถรถรถบัสกรุงเทพเชียงใหม่ครับอ้าแล้ว
คนขับรถบัสไม่สบายเจอแล้วบอกช่วยด้วยผม
ปวดท้องค่อยขับหน่อยขอกู Arty ไปช่วยก็
ข้างหน้าข้างหน้ามีมีปั๊มน้องไม่ได้พี่ไป
ขับได้ไหม
What  is ขับได้แต่ว่าแต่ว่าถ้ามีตำรวจ
ตำรวจตำรวจจับตำรวจจับชายน้ำเหมือนจับไม่
มีสิทธิ์ครับชายไม่มีใบขับขี่ทรายไม่มี
ใครเรื่องที่รถบัสใช่ครับเจอไปสอบค่ะครู
ปาร์ตี้
ที่ไม่ได้ขับรถบัสคนติ้งบ้านครัวตี้ที่
บ้านไม่มีรถบัสก็เคยพี่สอบเก็บเก็บไว้
ช่วยเค้า
โอเคในกระเป๋าตังค์มีบัตรประชาชนใช่ไหมมี
ใบขับขี่นะครับค่ะแล้วก็
บัดนี้ต้องมีครับวันนี้ต้องมีผู้เก๋มีไหม
อ่ะใช่เขาเป็นบัตร atm เออ
บัตร ATM ใช้ทำอะไรครับถ้าปัด SM ใช้ทำ
อะไรต้องเดินเดินไปแล้วก็มีตู้ตู้ AP  AR
แล้วก็กดกดอทเคเอาเงินมาได้เงินโอเคเงิน
ของเราอยู่ในตู้อีก
ทำบัตร ATM ต้องมีเงินเราต้องมีที่มี
อยู่ในแบงค์ได้แล้วถึงใช้บัตรเครดิต
ธนาคาร
ธนาคารใจครับคือตอนนี้คนไทยก็พูดแบงค์
เนาะครับแต่คนไทยก็เข้าใจเรียกแบงค์คนไทย
ก็เข้าใจใช่คนไทยพูด 2 คำธนาคาร
ทับศัพท์ภาษาอังกฤษ
แบงค์เพราะว่าถ้าธนาคาร 3 คำแบงค์ขับ
คนใดชอบเซ็นทรัล
พูดอัน
ก็มีบัตรเอทีเอ็มเลยครับ
เราไม่พูดภาษาไทยเนาะอ่ะเราภาษาไทยบัตรกด
เงินสดหรือยาว 3 คำเหมือนกันคำเข้าเหมือน
กันกดเงินสดอ่ะ
อาโนหมออ๋อยาวด้วยนะในนักเรียนเม็ดไม่
ต้องพูดภาษาไทยพูดทับศัพท์ภาษาอังกฤษค่ะ
คนไทย ATM คนไทยพูดบัตรกดเงินสดไม่พูด
นะเหอๆเด้อมีบัตรเอทีเอ็มนะครับแล้วก็มี
อ่ะมีบัตรบัตรเครดิต
ร้องขอดูบัตรเครดิตด้วยไหมครับค่ะมีไหม
เออมีแต่บัตรเครดิตเนี่ยบัตรเครดิตไม่
เหมือนบัตร ATM นะครับครูเอ๋ไม่เหมือนยัง
ไงคะใช่ครับไม่เหมือนว่าไม่ได้เหรอคะอ่า
กดเงินได้ครับแต่ว่าเงินเงินที่กดออกมา
ไม่ใช่เงินของเราค่ะไม่ใช่เงินของเราเป็น
เงินของธนาคาร
มันเรายืมเหรอเฮ้ยเรายืมเข้ามาใช่หาภาค
อื่นมาใช้ไหมครับแล้วเราก็แบบครับแบตบัตร
เครดิตจะทำอะไรเออบัตรเครดิตก็
ใช้ซื้อของได้นะครับไม่ต้องใช้เงินสดไม่
ต้องใช้เงินใช้บัตรเครดิตนี่
เออเออ
คู๋แม่บัตรเครดิต 1 ใบพอแล้ว
ธนาคารชอบโทรศัพท์บัตรเครดิตไหมคะบัตร
เครดิตไหมคะเออทำอีกไหมเอาอีกไหมออกไม่
เอาแล้วกูเอกก็บอกไม่เอาใช่ไหมเพราะว่า
เวลามีบัตรเครดิตแล้วไปซื้อของไม่ได้จ่าย
เงินรู้สึกสบาย
30 วันใบเสร็จมาขอหมดตกหมด 1 เดือนทุกๆ
เดือนก็ธนาคารก็จะบอกจะบอกว่าเออกู A ใช้
เงินไปเอาเงินมาคืนคงเส้นบางคืนก็ต้องไป
หาเงินมาเอาเงินไปคือช้าเตือนตัวเองก็ได้
มี 1 ใบพอแล้วแล้วด้วยครับแล้วก็มี 2 ใบ 3
ไปเหนื่อย
กูแอปปี้มีมะหยี่ใบขวดอี้มีอยู่ 3 ใบห้า
สามใบไงครับเนี่ยมี 3 ใบแต่ว่าบัตรเครดิต
ก็ดีอย่างเลยนะหรือเวลาไปกินอาหารนะคะนัก
เรียนขับบ้านที่จะบัดเขตเครดิตจะลดราคา
ได้ใช่ครับในบ้านไหมคะอาจจะลดราคา 20
เปอร์เซ็นต์นะคะ
ก็เลยกูอะติ๊กก็เลยมี 3 ใบสำหรับรถราคา
หรือเปล่าได้ใช่ครับ
แล้วก็อ้ามีบัตรประชาชนใบขับขี่บัตร
เอทีเอ็มบัตรเครดิตนะครับแล้วก็มีบัตร
อะไรอีกอะไรอะไรในกระเป๋าสตางค์น่ากลัว
ตี้ดูก่อนในกระเป๋าถ้ามีบัตรอันนี้ครับ
นี้มีๆมีบัตรบัตรประกันบัตรประกันใช่ครับ
เออ
ต้องใส่ไว้นะนักเรียนชายครับว่าใส่กันใช้
ทำอะไรคะหน้าบัตรประกันใช้เวลาที่เราไม่
สบายเราก็มีอุบัติเหตุ
อุบัติเหตุคือขับรถขับรถชนคนมึงใช่ครับ
แล้วเราเจ็บได้รับบาดเจ็บแล้วก็ฆ่าเอา
บัตรประชาชนไปโรงพยาบาลไปให้หมออยู่เออผม
มีผมมีบัตรประกันนะไม่ต้องจ่ายเงินเหรอ
เออไปป๊อปปี้บอยนะไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่บอกพี่บอก
เนิ่นๆเน้อใช่ครับรถพยาบาลหน้ารถพยาบาลก็
มารับไปโรงพยาบาล
สาย
ใช้ประกันนี้นะครับ
ครูอันที่ครูมีอันนี้มีอะไรครับครูเอ๋มี
MK สกี้ฮ่าๆเปิดอี้ไม่มีเลยช้าถ้าเป็น
บัตรส่วนลดใช่ไหมครับแต่วันค่ะอ๋อออ
สมาชิกสมาชิกบัตรสมาชิกเอมีนิดหน่อยนะคะ
นักเรียนไม่นิดหน่อยนะไปเยอะเหมือนกันนะ
อันนี้เอามา 3 นะคะผู้หญิงค่ะผู้หญิงนัก
เรียนซื้อของที่ไหนก็จะมีบัตรเจอบัตร
สมาชิก
สมัครมีบัตรสมาชิกเยอะเลยค่ะแต่ว่าของนิด
หน่อยมีประมาณ 7 ใบ
ภัย 7 ใบไม่มีนิดหน่อยไม่นิดหน่อยนิด
หน่อยปกติเพื่อนบางคนคู๋นี่มีอางอมากว่า
10 ใบขั้วตีนไม่มีเลยไม่มีเลยไม่มีเลย
เวลากูดีวันการ์ดแต่ว่าไม่ได้ใช้ใช้บอก
บอกเบอร์โทรศัพท์บอกเบอร์โทรศัพท์ใจไม่
ใช่การ์ดอันนี้ต้องบอกอ่ะอันนี้ต้องมีอัน
นี้เก่าแล้วนะเนี่ยเปลี่ยนใหม่อะไรเขาอัน
นั้นบัตรอะไรที่สุดขอ
บัตรสมาชิกได้ไหมครับ
ดอกไปมีบัตรอะไรอีกไม่มีอีกนะกวนตีนหัวตี
หมดแล้วโหดีไม่มีบัตรแล้วก็ที่ไม่พกบัตร
เยอะกู ami คุยมีเยอะประการก็มีอันนี้แบต
ร้านอาหารขอบัตรส่วนลดอีกแล้วไปส่วนลด
ร้านอาหารใช่ไหมครับอายอันนี้อาหารอาหาร
สำหรับคน
ถ้าผมแพ้ที่ไหน
แล้วก็มีตัวนี้นี่ควรที่มีไหมมีอะไรครับ
อันนี้บ้านอะไรอาเขาเรียกว่าบัตรสะสมแต้ม
อ๋ออ๋อบัตรสะสมแต้มเท
กี่คือกันหน้าร้านค่ะขนมอ๋อร้านนี้จะขาย
เค้กเค้กอีกละไปกินคุกกี้นะคะแล้วก็เวลา
เราซื้อน่ะค่ะถ้า 50 บาทแม่ 50 บาทเขาก็
จะมีมีมีตัวนี้ค่ะ
อะไรนะคะเนี่ยอะไรนะคนไทยไม่ชอบไปความใช่
ไหมตาประทับอะเนี่ยค่ะถ้าพระถ้า
50 บาทได้ 1 ครั้งประทับ 1 ครั้งขาย 9
ประทัดแล้วถ้า
หัวหน้าไปอีกคราวหน้าไปอีกประทับอีก 1
ครั้งให้อ๋อประทับ port เต็มปุ๊บก็ฟรีหก
สิบบาท
ในฟรีหกศูนย์เนี่ย 5 นะก็ก็คุยก็จะมีบัตร
สะสมแต้มอ๋อเป็นบัตรสะสมนะครับถ้าให้เอ
ไม่สะสม
สมผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงชอบสะสมแป้ง
มา
เอกครับเอ๋ทำเราทำเราทำบัตรหายครับเรา
ต้องทำยังไงครับครูเอ๋บัตรหายและบัตรอะไร
คะบัตรสะสมแต้ม
สะสมแต้มกว่าตีนไม่มีมีหายนะครับเออบัตร
อันนี้ค่ะ
BTS อ๋ออ๋อบัตร B ขอหน่อยครับเห็นไหมคะ
เห็นครับเป็นรูปกระต่ายใช่มั้ยเป็นรับ
Beach ได้ขึ้นรถไฟฟ้าใช่อันนี้หายนัก
เรียนต้องรีบโทรศัพท์แจ้ง BTS มาอ๋อ
กับเพราะว่าถ้ามีคนเอาอันนี้ไปอู้โหไม่
ไม่ไม่โอเคนะคะอันตรายหน่อยอันนี้มันจะ
เหมือนกับลิงค์กับบัตรประชาชนอ๋ออันนี้
ไม่ได้เฮ้ยหายจริงๆน่ะกูอ่ะตี้กระเป๋า
สตางค์หายทำยังไงคะถ้ากระเป๋าสตางค์หาย
เลยบัดก็จะหายไปด้วยเออพอบัตรหายเนี่ยเรา
ก็ต้องไปแจ้งตำรวจครับไปที่สถานีตำรวจ
ที่ไหนสถานีตำรวจที่สถานีตำรวจครับที่
สนานีกำหนดจะมีเป็นอย่างนี้ครับมี
สัญลักษณ์ไหนเออใช่ครับเป็นโล่แล้วก็มี
ดาบก็เป็นที่สถานีตำรวจที่ไหนก็ได้ใน
ประเทศไทยที่ไหนก็ได้ไปที่สถานีทั้งหมด
ที่ที่เรารู้ว่ากระเป๋าตังค์หายก็ไปที่
สถานีตำรวจได้พูดอะไรคะเดินเดินไปบอก
ตำรวจครับไปบอกไปบอกจากส่วนบอกว่ากระเป๋า
สตางค์หายเจอแล้วก็ก็มีบัตรอะไรที่หายไป
บ้างบอกเหลืองบัตรประชาชนบัตรเอทีเอ็ม
บัตรเครดิตหายบ่อยหลวงบัตรบัตรบัตร BTS
ราคา
บัตรสะสมแต้มไม่ต้องบอก
เธอ
บัตรสมาชิกร้านอาหารไม่ต้องบอกรายงานบอก
แต่บัตรที่
สำคัญสำคัญบาทที่เกี่ยวกับเงิน
มีบัตรที่เกี่ยวกับข้อมูลของเราเอออะไร
กับบอกตำรวจก็จะจดจดลงไปอะไรหายบ้างหาย
ที่ไหนหายเมื่อไหร่เจอใช้หมดจะถามอ่าบัตร
ATM กี่ใบครับใครครับปาร์ตี้มีกี่ใบนะ
หน้าบัตรเอทีเอ็มครัวตีไม่
ไม่มี
ATM อาบัติเครดิต
3 ใบครับ 3 ใบธนาคารอะไรครับเธอปวดดีก็
บอกชื่อธนาคารธนาคารกสิกรไทยธนาคารกรุง
ไทยธนาคารออมสิน
หรือว่าถ้าเป็นนักเรียนก็อาจจะนาคารอะไร
นะ
ธนาคารไหนธนาคารซิตี้แบงก์ cdu  a  d  e
r ยูโอบี UOB  Stand อาซาเตอร์
ของนักเรียนของเราก็ธนาคารไทยนางได้ครับ
หน้าก็ต้องบอกตำรวจให้ครับ
แล้วทำบัตรประชาชนหายด้วยถ้าบัตรประชาชน
หายก็บอกตำรวจเหมือนกันเสร็จแล้วเราก็
ต้องไปทำบัตรใหม่บัตรที่หายไปหาทำใหม่ถ้า
เป็นบัตรประชาชนบัตรประชาชนเราต้องไปทำ
ที่ที่ว่าการอำเภอ
ที่ว่าการอำเภอค่ะครับที่ว่าการเอาไปเผย
ก็จะมีรูปมีรูปนี้ครับนี่นกลูกนกตัวใหญ่
เลขอะไรนะครับคนไทยเรียกครุฑครุฑนะคะครุฑ
ที่ว่าการอำเภอค่ะครู Arty อันนี้ต้องไป
ที่บ้านตัวเองไหมหรือว่าที่ไหนก็ได้ที่
ไหนก็ได้ครับถ้าจะมีคอมพิวเตอร์มี
อินเตอร์เน็ตที่ไหนก็ได้นะคะ
ขายที่เชียงใหม่ก็อยู่เชียงใหม่ก็
เชียงใหม่นะฮะเอ๋น่ะเหรอบ้านอยู่ชลบุรี
ขับเดี๋ยวว่าอยู่กรุงเทพฯก็ไปที่กรุงเทพฯ
ได้ดาวอาทิตย์ปาร์ตี้มีคำถามครับผมเมื่อ
กี้อาจค่าบัตรบัตร ATM หายบัตรเครดิตหาย
ครับอัดแจ้งตำรวจเท่านั้นเหรอคะเออถ้า
บัตร ATM เอ่อก่อนที่จะแจ้งตำรวจเราต้อง
โทรไปโทรไปก็ใหญ่ขนาดคานก่อนเออถ้าบัตร
เอทีเอ็มบัตรเครดิตของครัวตี้เป็นธนาคาร
ออมสินควรตีก็ต้องโคไปที่ธนาคารออมสิน
ขาดแล้วบอกบอกบ้างอะไรขาดหายครับ
บัตรหายๆแล้วก็ขับโทรไปเพื่อให้เขาทำอะไร
ฮะเพื่อให้เขายกเลิกบัตรยกเลิกให้บัตรใช้
ไม่ได้
ว่ะไอเรียกว่าอายักไหมคะอายัดบัตรไอ้ครับ
น่าอายอายัดแล้วคิดว่าถ้าทักครูเอ๋เจอ
กระเป๋าอาทิอะเออเฮ้ยมีบัตรเครดิต
โอเคกูเอกไปไปนู้นแหละเออไปซื้อของ
ซื้อของซื้อของแล้วใช้บัตรใช่ไหมคะใช้
บัตรกู Arty ๆคิดเจอมาได้ก็ไปปั๊บถ้ากู
Arty โทรศัพท์ไปธนาคารอ้าวแล้วบอกว่า
อายัด
อายัดบัตรสายครับไปซื้อของอ่ะซื้อ
แอปเปิ้ลแล้วก็ว่างอ่ะแล้วก็ส่งบัตรกู
Arty แต่กูแอปปี้โทรศัพท์พี่ยัตบัตร
เสร็จแล้วพนักงาน
โอเคอ่าอันนี้
200 บาทค่ะเอกส่งบัตรเครดิตครู Arty
หนับพนักงานก็แอบแอบเองไม่ได้ค่ะบัตรใช้
ไม่ได้แล้วอ่ะบัตรใช้ไม่ได้แล้วเพราะว่า
ครัวตี้อายัดไปแล้วอาญาอะไรใครไม่ได้ต้อง
โทรไปถูกใช่ตั้งโทรศัพท์อันดับแรกเลยนะคะ
จะเป๋าสตางค์หายโทรศัพท์อายัดบัตรก่อนงาม
อะไร
อายับก่อนถ้าเราตำรวจโอ้โหมีคน
ไทยไปแล้วเนอะใช้งานต้องอายัดบัตรเครดิต
ก่อนนะครับใช่ค่ะ
นะคะก็เคยหายไหมจริงๆควรที่ยังไม่เคยยัง
ไม่เคยทำกระเป๋าสตางค์ค่ะผู้ชายบ่อยๆฮ่าๆ
ไม่ได้หายมีคนกูเองขึ้นรถเมล์ครับรถเมล์
ปาร์ตี้ขับรถไงกูเองนั้นเมย์
มีกระเป๋าของผู้หญิงแล้วก็มีคนกรีดแล้วก็
ขโมยหรอมีคนมาเอากระเป๋าไปเห็นไม่ได้ทำ
หายมีคนขโมยไปมีคนขโมยไป
3-4 คู่ประมาณ 5 หรือ 6 ครั้งโหโห
หลายครั้งเลย
โดนขโมยว้าวๆนอนขโมยเอกโทรโทรไปแบงค์ลาย
ครั้งมหายเหนื่อยมาก
ไปสถานีตำรวจดูก็เห็นตอนนี้ครูเอกมี
กระเป๋าใช่ไหมกระเป๋าผู้หญิงที่นี่แล้วก็
กอดเอาไว้อาต๋อ
ขึ้นรถเมล์ขึ้น BTS ก่อนเอาไว้ขโมยไหม
[เพลง]
หาวันนี้เราหมดเวลาแล้วครับสำหรับกระเป๋า
สตางค์แล้วก็บัตรต่างๆนะครับห่า ka คือ
ถ้าสำหรับนักเรียนนะคะนักเรียนอาจจะมีมาก
กว่านี้นิดนึงนะคะเพราะว่าในกระเป๋า
สตางค์ของนักเรียนอาจจะมีพาสปอร์ต
สังฆานเรียน Passport หายและนักเรียนต้อง
ไปสถานีตำรวจใช่เหมือนกันแจ้งความราคา
ต้องแจ้งความ
แล้วเพราะว่าในพาสปอร์ตจะมีใบที่สตางค์
บ้านนักเรียนเข้าประเทศไทยวันนี้ออกวัน
ไหนเกี่ยวกับวีซ่าเกี่ยวกับอะไรนะวันที่
เข้ามาในไปแจ้งความนะคะที่สถานีตำรวจ
เหมือนกันร่างนะครับวันนี้มีเวลาเนอะใช่
ครับหมดเวลาแล้วกดเวลาแล้วกันหน่อยนะครับ
ในคลิปหน้านะครับเราจะมาเล่าเรื่องอะไร
ให้ฟังเดี๋ยวนักเรียนคอยติดตามกันครับใน
ช่อง component  Store ไทยนี้นะครับให้
ข้านะคะอย่าลืมกด like กด Share กด
Subscribe
ด้วย
[เพลง]
กดเครื่องบินจริงๆด้วยนะครับพาอ่อนถ้านัก
เรียนอยากฟังเกี่ยวกับอะไร comment ได้
ไหมได้ครับได้ครับ comment ไว้ด้านล่าง
เลยกลัวนี่กูอยากฟัง
topic อะไรอ่ะบอกครูได้นะคะ
โอเคค่ะคลิปนี้ครูอาตีกับกู a ไปละใช้
ครับลาไปก่อนครับสวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋ซื้อ
สวัสดีค่ะน้องนัทดีสวัสดีค่ะนะครับอ่า
ม.ค